mama warum sich gehört der jungen oder
da noch 16 euro leute sich alle lieben
es auch anders geht auf und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video ja ich
hoffe natürlich euch geht es gut
und zwar belichtungen passt alles hier
so gut aus weil das uns machen was man
ein bisschen heller und die sonne
strahlt sogar noch rein hier auf jeden
fall habe ich mir für das heutige video
dass einiges tradition seite 2017 gibt
es jedes jahr etwa um diese zeit anfang
november
wir haben gerade oktober oder auf jeden
fall gibt es immer einen adventskalender
video von mir vor zwei jahren hatten wir
einen amazon adventskalender für 50 euro
letztes jahr hatten wir weitere amazonen
adventskalender
die ist allerdings auch im supermarkt
lebt von eigentlich hatte ich heute
geplant alle adventskalender aus dem
supermarkt zu kaufen es war echt viele
als natürlich nicht alle aus allen
supermärkten sondern alle aus einem
supermarkt waren trotzdem sehr sehr
viele und das problem war die waren alle
aus schokolade also da hat einfach nur
schokolade drin und das fand ich ein
bisschen schade weshalb ich mich jetzt
dazu entschieden habe einfach mal 3 zu
kaufen die mich am meisten ansprechen
und die so ein bisschen aufzuschlitzen
um halt zu sehen ob das es sich lohnt
die zu kaufen ich ich stelle euch die
gerne vor
für welche ich mich entschieden habe und
ich würde auch sehr gerne noch mich ein
bisschen drüber aufregen
als erstes haben wir mit 599 gekostet
ich bin das so traurig auf jedem
adventskalender von milka ist halt was
werbung drauf es war nicht genug es sich
bei allen so früher ich hatte mal wenn
es gelänge das waren halt so richtige
schöne dinge davon ein bisschen
schokolade drin und ein weihnachts
musterdorf heutzutage hast du denn drauf
was hatten in ganz kanada mit angry
birds 2 zu tun
auf jeden fall finde ich das eine
absolute frechheit so kleinkinder schon
ist werbung zu melden beim
adventskalender hatte ich nicht so was
das war früher nicht normal dass auch
matt vance in einer werbung ist oder
hast du das siehst du scheiße ich muss
mich auch noch ein adventskalender
kaufen oder tun also alles selbst
gemacht
als nächstes habe ich besorgt dieses das
finde ich so halbwegs cool ist praktisch
wie so ein buch hier kann man ja sehen
hat auch ordentlich gekostet 1699 habe
ich dieses ding hier mitgehen lassen und
irgendwann wenn ich mal gespannt was
mich hier erwartet weil das ganze ist
hier stehen nicht alle sachen drauf die
drin sind wir werden sehen und diesen
gab es letztes jahr auf jeden fall nicht
zumindest habe ich dann irgendwo
gefunden und celebrations also natürlich
sind da er so bonbons drin aber
eigentlich kann man ja mal mit dem
anfang für die leute die sich noch
überraschen lassen wollen auch so soll
das kein spoiler sein
dann schalten wir am besten ab weil ich
würde jetzt schon gerne den inhalt
prüfen und bevor wir hier jedes einzelne
kästchen auf machen es dauerte dies
machen wir uns doch einmal nicht so viel
arbeit da raus früher hat man sich ja
immer so versucht daran zu halten
jeden tag ein stückchen aufzumachen
heute schließlich drei kalender an einem
tag
ach so die einen sagen wir machen
wenigstens 24 markus aufmachen weil das
ist ja meistens so dass zwischen nächste
mal peter bonk
aber ich muss sagen immerhin mein
lieblings bonbon und nikolaus machen wir
noch auf die sechste wo ist das super ok
warte mal
[Applaus]
also man muss wirklich sagen
adventskalender an sich sind so ein
heftiges geschäftsmodelle
wir haben jetzt 24 bremste in einer
packung von denen sind doch 50 50 oder
60 drin und haben hier einen
spitzenpreis jetzt sagt 799 5 24
immerhin sind meine lieblingssongs dabei
hättest du dich als kind gefragt hättest
du so ein adventskalender zukunft na ja
gut ich hatte war eigentlich nur seinen
standard denke und weist also für 199
motto not schokolade drin ist habe ich
nebenbei mit also diesen kalender kann
ich euch schon mal erst mal so an sich
nicht empfehlen muss ganz ehrlich sagen
das ist noch weiter macht mit dieser
hier ist eigentlich am meisten
das ist einfach ein buch das finde ich
sogar noch cool magst du auch teuer
macht weiß dass es auch jetzt kommen wir
hier werbekalender ich weiß gar nicht
ist das ein adventskalender ist das ein
werbekalender die armen kinder
heutzutage werden schon mit sechs jahren
mit angry birds konfrontiert da kann
doch nicht gut laufen oder ich wollte es
ja eigentlich auch nach renz kalender
machen
leider war das zu kurzfristig und dies
habe nicht vergessen weil letztes jahr
hatte ich mich halt auch ziemlich früh
mit dem thema beschäftigt naja jetzt
stellt nur den nächsten auf ich bin mal
gespannt was hier drin ist der hass wie
gesagt fünf euro mehr kostet mal gucken
ob sich das lohnt
ich werde 100 euro auf schokolade
und im tannenbaum oh tannenbaum gibt es
einen bescheid wenn es geländer das ja
nochmal was können ja fliegen castrol
die man testen muss ich sagen ähnlich
wie der andere fünf euro 99 kann man
jetzt nicht meckern alles halt
ausgefallene schokoladen muster hier wie
zb dieser schneemann aber dann kauf dir
auf zwei tafeln schokolade zucker drin
dann hast du das genauso wieder drin gut
aber die kleinen kinder freuen sich
vielleicht schon über so was hat man
halt auch einfach überall das gleiche
bisher ein bisschen vollmilch schokolade
gefüllt mit so wie ich da wie auch immer
aber schmeckt ja gut aber mehr kann ich
dazu auch nicht sagen aber ich mache ja
sowieso jeden tag ein video 19 übrig
bleibt hinter die ohren aber den kanal
glocke aktivieren instagram alex wiens
neues video
ihr könnt mir also sehr gern auf
instagram wo ich alle kalender natürlich
auch verlosen werde viel spaß das nicht
könnt ihr mir fotos schicken von
irgendwelchen kalendern nicht mal testen
soll dann bestelle ich natürlich hat die
aus aber messen kalender oder schokolade
weil das ist glaube ich interessanter
aber wir haben ja noch ein und
vielleicht ist hier ja was ganz
besonderes drittel macht
geschichten aus shenzen ausstellen sind
kommen die ganzen großproduktionen so
deswegen lieber juni auch du sollst
dieses jahr ein tolles weihnachtsfest
genießen
deswegen schenke ich dir diesen kanälen
danach regelrecht aufgeschlitzt haben so
gut aber was man auch hier sind halt
schon extrem krass große sie ist dass
das uns auch hier angefangen bei der 10
oder wo wir noch nie kommen die 5 es
könnte ja weißt du was ich ein bisschen
schonen würde werden kinder joint aber
ist dass ein buch so dass sich diese
pixi bücher oder die hand gibt den
biwaks das bedeutet jetzt wahrscheinlich
in jedem park fenster hier ist ein
anderes buch
sie habe darum gelesen habe aber das
heißt doch die kinder haben gar keinen
bock die großen fläche auf zu machen
schildert leute was sie bei mir war es
immer so ich bin morgens aufgewacht habe
mich gefreut auf dieses kleine stückchen
schokolade und dann christ einfach so
ein buch
hast du auch teilweise sind manchmal
reingeguckt vorher schon was drin ist
na ja klar manchmal war der kalender und
nach zwei tagen leer
dann habe ich aber noch einen zweiten
gericht so mal gucken was ihr trainer 24
drin ist okay wenn du kannst doch in die
24 kein buch eintrugen
das ist doch für die brutal zum streber
kinder dann oder und dann freuen sich
jetzt alle und dann kriegt man hier zum
24 sonntag ein tiger und dann weiter zum
klar ist es für kleine kinder aber da
und dann auch noch 16 euro 99 also
irgendwann ist auch mal gut mama warum
tech gehört der jungen die advents
kriegen ja aber man muss sagen ich das
wenigstens abwechslungsreiche ja schön
aber die sollen aber irgendwie dann
meinen also ja okay an sich ich will das
jetzt auch gar nicht so ein buch ist
finde ich das geht dann wieder eher in
die richtige richtung als ist gerade der
fall ist weil ich war lässt uns zum
beispiel auch auf so ein event und da
haben die ganzen kinder halt vor teilt
gespielt und meinen sie gehen nicht mehr
zum fußballspiel sondern spielen den
ganzen tag verteilt und das ist
natürlich auch nicht richtig so oder ist
lesen bereich dann besser und bildet
auch aber da freut man sich natürlich
nicht drüber saucen weiße creator could
you be kinder bueno ihr sohn nikolaus
wahrscheinlich zum zum sechsten jahr
genau kinder country mini und als
blödsinn
aber davon habe ich euch ihr könnt mir
wie gesagt ein neuer kalender pence im
schicken oder schreibt sie und das video
am besten vorher instagram das schon das
beste was wir machen können
juli meinte gerade das gibt uns vor
schlendern eine sache die aber echt
witzig ist an die das jetzt nicht mehr
jugend wird man durchaus halten und zwar
mache ich ja zum black friday drei
riesen black friday opel ist mit allen
sachen wir schreiben ja andauernd gegen
welche genetischen unternehmen oder
verkäufer aus der ganzen welt kennen rio
ab und wir haben da unten schon kameras
drohne und so weiter und eine sache die
auch da ist die schiffe liegen die
handelt nämlich mit chinesischen
sexspielzeugen und die hat mir zwei
zukommen lassen wie wir uns das
anschauen
na gut das werden
also da kann der straffreien kommt
glaube ich am 27 28 und 29
nun mache ansonsten kann sollten wir
anfangen
wir sehen uns morgen 19 wieder gibt's
neues video